Okay, so in this section we're going to review the tracking solution for the options that you have available,
along with the plugins and system options that you have in your project.
So first thing we want to do is we want to make sure that in virtual production in ICD-FX, our plugins are working and active.
Now you need to make sure that if you're using OptiTrack or Vicon, any external program that you're using for your motion tracking or your performance tracking software
needs to be downloaded and installed on every single computer that is going to be talking to each other,
so every node for rendering needs to have all these plugins active.
Now most of them are going to live and exist already within the engine,
but if there are additional ones that you need, please make sure that you download them before you get started.
Additional plugins for DMX, VR, and XR can also be enabled depending on your production needs,
if you're going to do some live DMX lighting or some virtual scouting or any of the other tools that we have available for ICD-FX.
Now you'll note here in blue we have the Aja Media Player, Blackmagic Media Player, Camera Calibration, LED Wall Calibration,
OpenCV Lens Distortion, and the Live Link Camera and Live Link Lens plugins.
Those blue plugins are specific to ICD-FX, the orange plugins are specific to virtual production,
and the white plugins are additional virtual production plugins that are automatically active as well in the system,
but can be enabled as options for everything else.
Things like switchboard, ICD-FX, they all need to be enabled as you go through this.
Now, moving on to our tracking systems as well, there are several options that you have available.
Alate Stage that we've got here uses the OptiTrack Motive performance capture system for camera and object tracking,
nodal point calibration, and lens distortion mapping, as we've already seen,
but other solutions such as the Vicon Shogun and the Vive Tracker and Vive Mars systems are available as well.
One thing to note is that your camera tracking should be active as part of your stage setup,
and the tracking setup, including setting the origin point of 000 for your tracking volume,
camera calibration, and lens distortion mapping are covered in this previous course.
However, as you go through and do your calibration, you may notice that after your initial calibration,
the tracking volume might require some daily refinement to the calibration.
Refining the calibration should be done daily or several times a day to maintain the volume
and prevent tracking marker drift over time.
As you see here in these images, the OptiTrack Motive system and the Vicon Shogun system have similar tracking calibration options.
Typically, you're going to be looking for a residual mean error of less than one millimeter,
so 0.9, as you can see here, is a good result.
You want to get that residual mean error to be as low as possible.
That's going to give you a good calibration and a good tracking option.
Unreal Engine does require the installation of the tracking system plugins.
Just a reminder for you that on each machine that is connecting through Switchboard,
and for any additional resources, you can just visit the websites of any of the respective tracking systems that are out there.
So that's it for our tracking and calibration.
Next, we're going to talk about some of the other dependencies that we're going to need for tracking our camera.